- Hey everyone, it's Mark Wiens.
I am hangin out with my buddy.
- Anton Diaz.
- This is Anton.
And we are in Manila,
in the heart of Manila in Quiapo,
and we came here to eat
Filipino street food.
So we're gonna show you some of the most
iconic Filipino street foods,
right in Quiapo market.
(Filipino music)
Along with the Quiapo church,
which you can visit,
you can come here for
a really interesting,
unique market in Manila.
There's lots of street food there.
It's like a flea market,
an open air flea market,
where you can buy all sorts of things
and even just walking around here
and just observing the
cultures is very fascinating.
(announcement in foreign language)
So packed,
and there's so much going on
there's fruit,
there's a lot of fresh
ingredients as well.
But then I'm also seeing
a lot of dried fish,
a lot of street food snacks,
full of everything you can imagine,
and lots of street food
tucked in every corner.
(children singing)
Oh look at all these dried fish.
(people shouting)
- Sotanghon? You want Sotangon?
- [Mark] Yes, please.
It's called Tanghon?
Sotanghon.
The first street food we're gonna try is,
they have a number of different
noodle-looking dishes,
and I think this one is Mung Bean noodles,
and I'm not sure what else,
but some spices,
and it's made into kind of a soupy dish.
(people talking)
What is the name of this dish?
- [Anton] Sotanghon.
- [Mark] Sontanghon.
- Soup. So it's a glass noodle with egg,
and then palabok,
one of the popular Filipino pansit.
- [Mark] We just got some front row seats
on some chef's table, yeah.
Okay.
There's an egg in here,
there's the Mung Bean noodles,
they're long beans,
there's shallots.
Oh and there's some bits
of meat in here too Anton.
Oh it's hot! Mmm! Oh yeah.
It's a little bit salty and a little bit,
kind of like oily,
the broth is kind of oily,
but then those noodles,
they just kind of slide right down,
you barely need to chew
them and they just slide.
I'm gonna dig into this egg.
Oh yeah, an egg makes everything better.
Oh yeah.
You cannot eat this fast
because it's so hot.
Oh that yolk is on fire.
So now you can do some seasoning,
so I'm gonna squeeze in a calamansi,
give it a little bit of
a citrusy-ness to it.
And then also,
this is like fish sauce.
Add in a little bit of fish sauce.
Sprinkle in some pepper.
(dishes clatter)
This is really a slurping,
oh, that almost slurped
right out of my mouth,
this is really a dish you've gotta slurp.
Just been given some rice cakes,
and these are like,
I think they're steamed rice cakes.
Break a piece of this,
and they said that it should be eaten
along with the soup.
It's a little bit sweet,
and very very spongy.
And a little bit sour as well.
This little street food stall is so tight
that we had to set up the camera
across the food from us
so then Anton and I had got front row,
these are the best seats in the whole
street food stall.
(Anton laughs)
And we just finished with our bowl
of the glass noodles,
and now we've got another dish.
What's this dish?
- [Anton] This dish is palabok.
- [Mark] Palabok?
- Yeah, and also, actually,
(Anton speaks Filipino with vendor)
topped with poku, tinapa, chicharon.
- [Mark] Chicharon, okay.
- Before you eat it, you have to
- Squeeze out some calamansi?
- [Anton] Of course!
- [Mark] Of course!
(both laugh)
- [Anton] And you also eat it with puto,
the rice cake.
- Oh this is a great atmosphere.
(Anton laughs)
Awesome place.
And then the key to this dish
is you've gotta fully mix it all
with the sauce, with the noodles,
with all those toppings,
that chicharon in there.
and there's minced meat
I think in here as well?
- [Anton] Yeah, yeah,
tinapa, which is fish.
- [Mark] Oh and fish also?
And tofu?
So there's a lot of ingredients
in this little plate of food.
You gotta eat it fast
before it all slides off your fork.
That's awesome man!
It's kind of like goopy.
But then you've got,
what I can really taste is
the fried garlic in there.
The fried garlic is really nice in there.
And it's like goopy and sticky
and this is just a wonderful street food,
Filipino street food.
Thank you very much!
Thank you very much.
- Thank you, bye bye.
- [Mark] Sarap.
- Sarap.
- [Anton] And you say salamat.
- [Mark] Salamat.
Okay that was absolutely awesome.
And you just cannot get a better
street food environment than that.
(Filipino music)
This is a market where you can come
to really get a feel of the real Manila.
It really feels like
you're in the heart of Manila here.
The action, every,
there's so many things for sale
and people are really friendly
at this market as well.
Hello!
- Hello!
- It's a great place.
When you're in Manila,
this is a place you wanna come explore
if you wanna really feel
the culture of Manila.
(people shouting)
It's very busy today.
Is it like this every day?
Oh okay, it's like this every day.
(music playing in distance)
This is a super human traffic jam.
Alright we made it
through that intersection.
(announcement over crowd)
- [Anton] One of the iconic places here
is the Quiapo Church.
- Okay, and we're standing right next to
Quiapo Church right now.
- Yes, and it's home
to the Black Nazarene,
which is very miraculous.
People believe if you pray to,
if you have a devotion
to the Black Nazarene,
it creates miracles in your life.
- [Mark] Wow that's awesome.
(announcer over crowd)
- [Anton] When we were
growing up as a child,
so fish ball, fish ball carts.
- [Mark] Are they all fish balls?
Is there chicken balls as well?
- No, this is fish ball,
squid ball, and what you call kikiam,
like a Chinese.
- [Mark] All mixed?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Yeah, so you just get.
- [Mark] We're standing
right in front of the church
so it's a little loud.
I hope you can hear me.
And so Anton,
you just grab a stick yourself?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And then you just
poke whatever you want.
- Yes, but you get the toasted ones,
usually the brown ones.
- [Mark] You want the brown ones
because those are more crispy.
- Yeah, in a sense.
- [Mark] Okay, so you then just
choose as many as you want on a stick.
- Yeah, ah you can put it here, yeah.
- You just choose as many
as you want on a stick
and then you add the sauce, okay.
- You can, now it's water,
and you have to, you can put it in a cup.
- [Mark] Oh you have a
fork here to push it on.
(Mark and Anton laugh)
That's awesome.
Come on.
(man singing over speaker)
Alright.
Then you stick it in the cup?
- [Anton] Yeah, you put it in the cup.
Then you put,
- [Mark] And then you move over to the
sauce station
- [Anton] Sauce bar, yeah.
- [Mark] Where you add in your own
sauce into the cup.
- Filipino food is known for sauces.
- And lots of vinegar as well yeah?
- Lots of vinegar, lots of sauce,
so you can add with
onions, with chili, yeah.
And so you usually have a cup
so that people don't double dip,
so you create your own sauce.
- I think this is my favorite sauce here.
And you take the spoon.
(stall owner shouts)
Oh ya that looks good.
Do I need more, or is that good?
- [Anton] Yeah just put more, and vinegar.
- [Mark] Add some more vinegar.
- [Anton] Alright, and then.
- [Mark] And add some more sauce?
- [Anton] Yeah, this is sweet.
- [Mark] I'll just go with vinegar,
let it absorb all of that vinegar,
and those onions, and those chilis.
Grab some of those chilis.
Alright I got three different
types of fish balls here.
(choir singing)
Oh it's still pretty hot!
It kind of has a gooey texture.
The vinegar mix is what
really makes it good.
The vinegar and those onions and chilis.
Oh look at that bite.
(choir singing)
They're like hardy fish balls.
- [Anton] These are a childhood favorite.
Brings back childhood memories.
You know and having mass,
and then after mass.
- [Mark] Okay.
And I love the culture of just
standing here around the cart, eating.
It's so atmospheric and so much fun.
Anton was just talking to the owner
of this street food stall,
and he actually said that
they are chicken balls.
- Yeah, because they like it bigger,
and it's two pesos.
- Two pesos per ball that we just ate?
- Per ball yeah.
So it's more profitable.
- Ah okay.
- The fish balls are smaller
and one peso or less.
- [Mark] Okay, okay so they're
actually chicken balls here.
And then right next door
to the chicken ball stand
is a dried squid stand.
And this looks delicious.
I smelled it,
and I knew that's what
we need to eat next.
These are just the squid bodies.
And then I'm also gonna get,
two please.
And those are the squid heads.
So those are just gonna grill,
those are gonna toast over the hot coals,
it looks really fast.
Go ahead, go ahead.
- [Anton] With chili, of course!
- [Mark] Chili.
- [Anton] Tastes so good.
- [Mark] Tastes so good.
- [Anton] Yeah.
- [Mark] You need to get
a lot of onions on there.
Is it onions or shallots?
- [Anton] Onions, yeah?
- [Mark] And what you can do is
you can try to scoop up as much onions
and chilis and vinegar as you can
on top of your squid.
Alright man.
- Alright.
(both laughing)
- I was trying not to do that.
They're really tight.
They're really tight on the skewer
so if you pull too hard
all the onions come flying off.
- [Anton] That's what happens.
- Oh, that's amazing though.
Oh that's delicious.
It's like, yeah,
it's salty dried squid.
Has a little bit of a crispiness to it.
And then,
hello.
- Hi.
- But I love it with that
vinegar and those onions.
- [Anton] Yeah.
- That's delicious.
That is a wonderful Filipino street food.
- Hey, we have to go, because of the mass.
- Oh.
- You have to dip this.
- Okay.
What's your name?
- Patrick.
- [Anton] This is yours.
- [Mark] You can have that.
- Nano.
- Natali.
- [Mark] My name is Mark.
- Patrick.
- [Mark] Patrick. Nice to meet you.
(speaking Filipino)
- [Mark] Bye bye.
Quiapo market, there's two sides, right?
- [Anton] Yeah, yeah.
- One is by the church,
surrounding the church.
- And one is around here.
- [Mark] So we just
crossed over the street.
(woman speaking Filipino)
Oh do you pick and choose?
Oh you get bowls.
Oh okay.
(Anton speaking Filipino with vendor)
We are at the next street food stall,
and here we're gonna eat kwek-kwek,
which are,
it's one of the most famous of all
Filipino street foods.
- Yeah, it's quail egg.
Quail egg with flour.
- Looks like it's ready.
Thank you.
And then you add your own sauce.
These are one-day-old chickens.
And she deep fried them
and then she put it on
top of our kwek-kwek,
which are quail eggs with flour batter
deep fried around it.
And so then you move
over here to the sauce,
condiment station.
Gotta go in for some onions.
And also a lot of that chili, oh yeah.
A one-day-old with some good chili on it.
And then I think I'll just go straight
for the vinegar next.
You can never have too much vinegar
on a one-day-old.
(Filipino music)
(Anton speaks Filipino to vendor)
Okay.
- It's so good.
- It's boney.
It's crispy.
It's like meaty, it's rubbery.
Okay, next up are the kwek-kwek,
which are quail eggs in the batter.
And I think you can one-bite this as well.
Oh yeah, that is a big mouthful.
But you got the really creamy egg yolk
in the center
and then it's like crispy
and very fluffy batter on the outside.
Alright, so we are moving on
to the next street food.
(Filipino music)
So this is for takeaway.
Very cool, yeah, the national sport.
Basketball is the favorite
sport in the Philippines.
So you'll just walk around
in the neighborhoods
and basically in any spare
place throughout Manila
you'll see little basketball courts.
So this is just in the neighborhood.
What's up man?
Hi.
Watch out.
(kids speaking Filipino)
Watch out, watch out.
(car engine rumbles)
Yeah, balut.
- [Vendor] 18, oh maybe 16, 17.
- [Mark] These are duck eggs right?
- [Vendor] Duck eggs.
Anton and I still have not eaten
the most famous,
or maybe it's the most infamous,
Filipino street food,
and that is balut.
- Balut.
- [Mark] And Balut is a duck egg
which is partly fertilized,
it's an embryo.
- [Anton] Yeah, and
usually it's 16, 18 days.
These one are 18 days old, okay.
- Okay so they have different stages
of the duck egg.
You can get one that's eight days,
or you can get one that's six, 12 days,
or 16 days, or 18 days.
- Or 18 days.
- 18 days. That's what he
said, these are 18 days?
- So, if it's 18 days,
just imagine you would see the
chicken developed already, in a sense.
- [Mark] A more developed chicken.
- Yeah, with beak.
(Anton laughs)
- [Mark] With feathers and, okay.
- [Anton] More developed duck, sorry.
- Okay so he said he has 18-day-old balut,
and that's what we're ordering right now.
Here's the balut.
Oh it's nice and hot.
This is a steamer so the
eggs are kept nice and hot.
And this is a pretty good-sized egg.
Check that out.
That's a fistful and
it's very nice and warm.
(vendor speaking Filipino)
Crack this egg?
This one yeah?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay, alright.
- So the pointed one.
- Oh the pointed side down.
It's pretty even.
Oh this is the pointed side?
- Yeah this one is pretty
even, but they know.
(both laughing)
- [Mark] Okay so then you crack it.
(egg shell cracking)
And then kind of peel back
a little bit of that.
There should be some soup in here right?
- [Anton] Yes.
- One of the best things
about eating balut
in the Philippines is that
there are many different components
all in a single shell.
So first you've got to drink the soup.
There's some natural juices and soup
inside of the shell, so
you drink that first.
- Alright.
- Oh that's delicious.
(Anton laughs)
Oh, that's just like
concentrated chicken soup.
- Yeah, it's chicken soup.
- Oh wow.
That's like the purest of all chicken soup
because there's no added anything,
it's just straight from the shell.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Oh yeah, you can now see
you can start to see the embryo in there.
- [Anton] The hairs.
- Oh the hairs, oh some juices.
Alright, there we go, yeah
you can see those feathers.
- [Anton] Wow.
- [Mark] You can definitely
see those feathers now.
Okay I'm gonna add some salt.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And vinegar, chili vinegar.
Okay, I'm gonna season my balut next.
So add a little bit of salt.
- [Vendor] A little bit, a little bit.
- [Mark] Alright, a little
bit of salt on there.
And then, so I wanna
get some chili vinegar,
which is my,
yeah this is my seasoning,
my condiment of choice in the Philippines.
(Anton chuckles)
Oh yeah, season that
with some good vinegar.
- [Anton] Oh, yeah. Yeah good.
- You can definitely
see all of the feathers,
all of the feathers on this balut.
That is 18 days old.
Okay I'm gonna go in for the chick
since it's on the top here.
Oh I think that is a
chicken foot right there.
See that?
- [Anton] Ah yeah.
- [Mark] Alright.
Wow, those are definitely feathers.
There's no denying that in your mouth.
But they are kinda like slimy feathers
with a very strong poultry flavor.
A very strong like duck,
actually I taste more of a chicken flavor
than a duck flavor.
- [Anton] That's the best part.
- [Mark] That's a giant yolk, wow.
- [Anton] Ah that's so yummy.
- [Mark] Wow look at that,
Anton check that out man.
- [Anton] Ah yeah, very good.
- Oh that yolk is gigantic.
I think I'm gonna add a little more of the
chili vinegar on this bite.
You can never have enough chili vinegar
in the Philippines.
When you're eating Filipino street food
that is the, one of the ultimate flavors.
Oh yeah.
- That's the best part.
- That is awesome.
(Anton laughs)
Oh it's just like so creamy,
but it tastes almost like
it's whipped a little bit.
Really creamy and fluffy.
And then at the bottom of your balut
you have this like rock hard,
what is it?
- It's the white part.
- That's the white that's undeveloped?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's the white part of the egg
that it's undeveloped,
and it's like rock hard
so you don't eat that.
That was delicious.
(Anton chuckles)
I'm not saying that balut is something
I would crave all the time,
but I think it's actually
tastes pretty good,
and it is quite fun to to eat as well.
It's like the ultimate
hard-boiled duck egg
that you could possibly have.
Within a shell you have all
the different components
and all the different textures and tastes.
And it's so pure,
it's all just in a single shell.
When you come to the Philippines
Balut is something,
if you're up for an adventure,
you gotta try balut,
and yeah, I think it's
pretty delicious actually.
We have come to the end of
this Filipino street food tour,
in Quiapo, Manila.
- Yes.
- Go check out Anton,
he's Our Awesome Planet.
- Yeah, in YouTube, Our
Awesome Planet Originals.
- Yeah and I'll leave his links
in the description box below.
He's also making videos
on YouTube and Facebook.
And he's just a cool guy.
- Yes!
- And we've been great eating friends
for many years now.
- For many years.
- I wanna say a big
thanks to you too Anton
for taking me around.
- [Anton] Thank you Mark
for being really cool about
eating all the street food.
- [Mark] That was a lot of fun.
- [Anton] Yes it is.
- And thank you very much
for watching this video,
please remember to give it a thumbs up,
click like on this video,
and also if you're not already subscribed,
make sure you subscribe for lots more food
and travel videos.
Goodbye from Quiapo in Manila.
Thank you for watching.
- Alright.